for thousands of years bees have been
symbols of mindless industry we always
think of them as being something like
biological robots doomed to live out
their lives in lockstep shackle to the
dreary roles assigned to them by nature
this is our first contact story it
happened in a place called rune link'll
in rural austria in the early 1900s
from the time Karl von Frisch was a
child he longed to understand what the
other animals knew how they perceived
the world he wanted to know if tiny fish
saw color or had a sense of smell he
invented experiments to explore animal
experience and he filmed them starting
in the early 20th century he was the
first to use the new medium of motion
pictures to create popular science
entertainment and communication for
thousands of years humans have noted the
eccentric dances of the bees but no one
had ever looked at them with the kind of
respect that assumed that was a reason
to their dancing before Karl von Frisch
no one ever thought to ask why they move
this way in that way in a succession of
elaborate figure Eight's von Frisch
studied every tiny bee gesture and
became fascinated by a mystery he
couldn't explain he would set out a dish
of sugar water for bee from his
experimental hive the bee would feast
upon it before flying back home
the marked bee would later return to
dine of the delicious sugar Warner von
Frisch noted that in just a few hours a
multitude of other bees would join her
there
they were always her fellow hive mates
but here was the really amazing thing
von Frisch knew that the other bees had
not followed the mark bee to the feeding
place how because he had the hive
closely watched at all times he had been
careful to use sugar water and not honey
so that the bees sense of smell could
not guide them to the reward he
continued to move the dish of sugar
water farther away until it was several
kilometers from the hive still the hive
mates would find their way to it so how
did the painted bee reveal the exact
location of the sugar war with such
precision that her hive mates could uh
never find their way there there was a
secret message in her choreography what
had seemed to countless generations of
observers to be nothing more than the
meaningless spasmodic motions of a dumb
animal was actually a complex message an
equation informed by mathematics
astronomy and an acute knowledge of time
all synthesized to convey the location
of the riches she hoped to share with
her sisters
[Music]
the dancer used the angle of our star
the Sun to indicate the general
direction of the food's location von
Frisch noted that when it be danced
straight upward she meant fly toward the
Sun and when she moved downward she
meant fly away from it
her swivels left and right conveyed the
foods exact coordinates in space
sometimes kilometers away
[Music]
the duration of her dance down to a
fraction of a second indicated the
length of time it would take her fellow
bees to get there she even factored in
wind speed to more finely calibrate the
message she danced and this was true at
any time of the year and from hive to
hive from continent to continent bees
can do the math
[Music]